hallo mein name ist luca und es gibt
fakten über milch und die sagt sag ich
euch heute mein lieblings youtuber ist
teddy comedy mein herz hat kann er noch
youtube hieß rumpel grammys fragt mich
nicht warum ich bin derzeit übel süchtig
nach dem neuen animal crossing spiel für
iphone und sagt dass circa 25 stunden am
tag ich frühstücke eigentlich nie falls
sich allerdings trotzdem frühstücken
sollte dann eigentlich immer mies wie
nie was anderes ich liebe es moody's
über alles außer es gibt doch heute und
morgen 20 prozent in meinem shop mit dem
kot luca 20 also besucht mal denn der
minister von de jetzt mein jetziges
handy eigentlich noch nie hingefallen
außer einmal aber das nicht kaputt
gegangen ich habe einen bachelor of arts
also bin ich eigentlich gar nicht so
dumm wie ich aussehe
das ist auf einen kaktus und alle
pflanzen meiner wohnung plastik pflanzen
weil ich nicht weiß wie man gießt ich
bin gerade erkältet hilfe ich bin ein
meter 93 groß und viele die mich in echt
von euch treffen die sagen auch aus dass
ich groß bin
danke wird sie noch gar nicht ich wäre
bei meiner geburt fast gestorben weil
die nabelschnur meinen kopf gewickelt
war und ich dann fast erstickt wäre oder
musste der chefarzt kommen und da hat
mich gerettet mein buch erscheint am 14
dezember und da gehen wir auch noch mal
näher auf die nabelschnur geschichte
unter anderem ein als kind hab ich's
ultra gebiet wenn mich meine eltern nach
dem duschen oder baden gefüllt haben
weil 52 ist mein traumauto ist der
mercedes 300 sl flügeltürer spitzenkader
kosten leider ein paar millionen ab
heute erfahren dass instagram für
instant telegram steht ja ganz schön
mollig mein manager heißt er ja hallo
mein name ist ilja und auf instagram
heißt luca nicht wege 83 kilogramm
ich bin eine zeitlang fünf monate am
stück nicht ins schwimmen gegangen habe
allerdings trotzdem jeden monat 50 euro
mitgliedsbeitrag gezahlt
ich wolle die ausmache youtube videos
nun seit mehr als sechs jahren
obwohl ich gerade mal fünf jahre alt bin
ich habe zu hause bei meiner familie
eine view um stimme der ich genau
zweimal
gespielt habe weil die beste investition
aller zeiten wurde hier unten ein
muttermal rausgenommen und das wohl dann
eingesendet weil ich schauen wollen doch
das böse hat dich ist war es dann
allerdings nicht
und jetzt bin ich kerngesund und mir
fehlt muttermal am ersten zwölfter
launischen fünf neue produkte im
vitalinus de ich bin morgens aus dem
haus gegangen und heraus gesehen das
licht angelassen als ich dann abends
wieder zu hause ankam dachte ich dass
ein einbrecher in meiner wohnung sei dem
kopf ich liebe chinesischen gebratenen
reis könnte ich 25 stunden tag essen
dabei insgesamt fünf jahre basketball
vier jahre tennis und sieben jahre
fußball gespielt ich bin eine richtige
sport höre ich bin stolzer fan des fc
bayern münchen
hättet mich ruhig ich wohne derzeit in
köln und will auch niemals irgendwo
anders entziehen
außer london bernische hamburger box
auch schön
mid münchen münchen wie ich es sehe ich
auch ganz nah ich trinke nur stilles
wasser weil das ist still und ruhig hält
seine schnauze
ich werde am 21 februar 2008 122 jahre
alt ich alter sack ich möchte später
unbedingt einen sohn haben und dass der
junge dann noch eine kleinere schwester
hat das wäre dream family eine video
ideen kommen ja entweder unter der
dusche oder auf dem klo ist das nicht
toll ich wenn ich im winter autofahrer
dann immer mit sitzheizung weil dann
wird mir heiß obwohl ich eigentlich
schon heiß bin aber dann wird mir noch
heißt mein lieblings dj sami fahmi falls
du das siehst dann verstehst du mich
nicht weil du bist franzose ich bin
single wer hätte es gedacht ich würde
bereits circa 40.000 mal von
essenslieferanten
einem autogramm für den sohn oder die
tochter gefragt das essen habe ich dann
trotzdem nie von den umsonst bekommen
ich habe mich auf einigen plattformen
wie beispielsweise snapshot oder
instagram laser luca genannt weil ich ja
auf youtube kontrakte heißt see und dann
wollte ich bei / etwas persönlicheres
mit luca aber wollte trotzdem das ist
ein l&s und luca und platten luca hört
sich blöd
deswegen hab ich dann laserdrucker
genommen ja ich habe nie wirklich
dragonball geguckt sondern bei immer
mehr so der irgendwie oben pokemon typ
sein lieblingsessen ist burrito könnte
ich vier millionen stück von und am tag
ich weiß zwar wie man wäscht und habe
sogar meine waschmaschine und ein
trockner dem er allerdings trotzdem noch
ab und zu was sachen mit zu meiner
mutter nach hause weil ich angst habe
dass ich das die beim einlaufen also
eigentlich kann ich doch nicht so
richtig waschen während meiner uni zeit
habe ich mir notizen eigentlich immer
auf dem college block gemacht weil diese
ganzen notizen auf den laptop und zudem
habe ich nicht so wenig vertraut weil
irgendwann hätte ich die locker aus
versehen gelöscht und dann wär halt blöd
das einzige playstation spiel was ich
regelmäßig zocken fifa hört sich
langweilig an ist aber egal wie meine
youtube-videos hören sich auch
langweilig an sind aber geil
als motto ich kann recht gut ski fahren
jedoch überhaupt nicht snowboarden weil
ich so nie probiert habe und auch nicht
probieren will weil skifahren ist cooler
ja meine mutter ist die beste köchin der
welt
manchmal wenn du das siehst du wirst
sehen ich sehen wenn ich bei meiner
familie zu hause in bielefeld bin kann
ich videos nur aufnehmen wenn es draußen
hell ist war ich dort keine videoleuchte
habe und ich nehmen videos eigentlich
gern auf wenn es draußen dunkel ist nur
dass das geht dann halt da nicht meine
instagram bilder bearbeitet ein kollege
von mir weil ich davon überhaupt keine
ahnung habe wenn ich kann bin ich
eigentlich nie irgendwelche medikamente
oder wenn ich kopfschmerzen habe nämlich
auch mir aspirin oder eine idee da
irgendwie so sondern ja immer nur
frische luft und wasser ich finde das
hat eigentlich alles das mikrofon an
meiner kamera hängt auch an zwei
gummibändern fest also klickt man auf
die werbung dann kann ich mir vielleicht
ein neues micro kaufen bei meinem ersten
dj mischpult ist mit dem crossfader
abgebrochen und dann statt dass sie
zu feiern ihr geschickt habt so dass es
repariert werden kann habe ich einfach
ein lineal als crossfader benutzt ja
nicht mehr ingenieure hauptberuflich ich
trage nie mützen und das war fakt nummer
50 coole super langweilig das video
aller zeiten
das watt ist ihr vom video der damen und
herren wenn es euch gefallen hat und ihr
ist geil findet wie geil ich bin halt
dann wollt dann lasst gerne mal ein
leichter und schreibt man in die
kommentare fakten wenn ich öfter fakten
videos machen soll wie ihr das über mich
leer und die dinge die ich euch gerade
berichtet habe werden auch mein buch
behandelt habe ich auch gerade schon
gesagt dass kommt am 14 12 raus da geht
es um viele sachen die mir in meiner
kindheit widerfahren sind in meiner
mutter mit allen bla bla bla bla auto
los verpisst euch das was ihr vom video
das war es jetzt hier vom video hier
können jetzt hier mal den kanal
abonnieren oder hier unten meinen job
ausschenken jetzt findet ihr zwei andere
videos und wenn ihr schon abonnent sein
können die auf die glocke klicken dann
willkommen die benachrichtigungen
[Musik]